Matthew how are you hi yeah I'm not
great it's I'm trouble sleeping I feel
like I can't turn my brain off like I
guess just these doors that's our time
what our time is up that's our time but
we have an hour
I know but typically when a therapist
says we're booking an hour it's
understood between both the patient and
the doctor that it's a 50-minute hour
and that's our time right now I
understand the whole 50-minute hour
thing but I've only been here like a
couple minutes
yeah I understand your confusion and
that's our time no thank you
you need to explain this to me because
I'm not following
let's just say I took the 50 minute hour
thing the logical next step I now have a
therapist 10 second minute and that's
our time no that's our time this doesn't
make any sense I'm going to explain it
to you next week I actually have a
patient coming in after you actually I
have about 32 patients after you with
the whole ten second minute thing I can
see about 64 patients a day I am making
Bank
yeah I'm making so much Bank I'm doing
random graffiti around London I am
Banksy and that's our time wait and then
it's our time no no hey hey hey hey
that's our time wait I want to absolute
but you are come past our time that's
our time this is ridiculous okay no
seriously if they have ten seconds is a
minute and fifty minutes is an hour then
I have over eight minutes sounds like
you have some anger issues we should
talk about that next time because that
is our time I tell you what all right I
am gonna leave and I'm not coming back
next week cancel it you want to cancel
next week's lunch just did I'm sorry I'm
gonna have to charge you for that I have
a 24-hour cancellation I was like it's a
week that's seven days seven of your
days that's seven of my hours time
speeds up so much in this office it
actually speeds up exponentially more
outside of the office it's called the
butterfly effect Ashton Kutcher this
makes no sense
I understand makes no sense in your time
but I'm talking about our time what is
our time that's what Oh
that's our time
you